nous voilà aux commandes d'un bolide à
100 km/heure à seulement quelques
centimètres du sol
c'est la course de drones voici votre
engin il pèse moins d'un kilo
il est piloté en immersion par ce casque
le pilote est à bord grâce à une petite
caméra
mais le festival du drone de cabourg
c'est aussi un salon pour les curieux
ici on peut s'essayer à piloter voilée
maniement et là tu regardes la radio
pour voir un peu le détournement de
l'appareil
des fois où qu'on voit un peu trop c'est
dur mais quand ça va c'est pas trop
compliqué c'était le cadeau de l'année
dernière et on se rend bien compte
aujourd'hui parce que techniquement on
n'a plus besoin de leur montrer à droite
à gauche levier dégâts s'il le
connaissent donc c'est assez marrant
justement des drones de toutes les
tailles pour tous les usages du jouet à
l'outil
le drone à tout faire c'est de la prise
de vue c'est des techniques de de
cartographie et puis ça va plus loin ça
peut aller pour les pompiers pour aider
à détecter des départs d'incendié ce
genre de choses c'est un les drones
décollent dans tous les sens pour tout
le monde c'est ça qui est cher les
journalistes aussi s'empare de cet outil
délicat et fascinant
c'est beaucoup plus dur que ça en a
l'air au moins j'ai ans 300 heures en
trois ou quatre cents heures de vol sur
garonne
je sais pas quoi faire drone presse est
une agence spécialisée dans les
tournages par drones une façon de capter
l'image qu'ils donnent des résultats
impressionnants
le film qu'ils ont réalisés sur la
jungle de calais ce camp illégal de
migrants sera projeté dimanche à cabourg